stanislas guérini bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nos députés de
paris délégué général de la république
en marche en étant 100 pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse jean yelle
régional bonjour pascal jalabert du
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france
cette année c'est zeleny l'allemagne a
donc classé la moselle en zone à risque
à partir de demain il faudra un test
négatif de -2 48 heures pour se rendre
en allemagne si on et mosellans et même
si on est travailleur frontalier qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette décision
c'est une décision difficile que les
allemands emprise on l'a regretté
parce qu'il faut toujours beaucoup de
concertation beaucoup de coopération
dans ces moments là mais la france s'est
battue n'a pas laissé tomber les seize
mille travailleurs frontale et mosellans
c'est un sujet de bataille pour clément
bonne le secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes pour ne pas que les
frontières soient véritablement fermé
c'est à dire que les travailleurs
frontaliers vont pouvoir continuer à
aller travailler c'était l'essentiel
avec des conditions qui vont être certes
compliqué il faudra un test mais qui ont
été amoindries par rapport à ce qui
était envisagé initialement ce qui était
envisagé initialement
c'était un test pcr toutes les 24 heures
ça rendait les choses extrêmement
compliqué la france est battue a fait en
sorte que ça puisse être des tests
antigénique tous les 48 heures que les
travailleurs puissent continuer à faire
leur boulot je pense que l'essentiel est
assuré mais c'est vrai cela pose
question
c'est une décision difficile et on va
continuer en tout cas c'est la position
que la france va tenir continuer à tenir
annoncé en europe et un dance justement
vous le dites il faut se battre face à
l'allemagne
est ce que c'est un coup de canif dans
la relation françois lallemand riche
dans d'un dan laksaw frankoual la france
par la voix de son secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes a été très clair
elle a dit qu'elle a regretté la
décision allemande moi je pense que à
chaque fois que l'on amoindri la
coopération qui a été quand même
rappelons le une force dans cette crise
sanitaire faut se souvenir des
démarrages difficiles au début de la
première vague puis ensuite la
mobilisation formidable moi j'ai pas
oublier quand même que les hôpitaux
allemands ont accueilli des patients
français qui a eu des transports entre
pays à ce moment là que la coopération
européenne a permis de commander
ensemble des vaccins tout ça a
fonctionné que on a voté il ya quelques
temps un plan de relance qui est
historique pour l'union européenne tout
ça a fonctionné
je pense que c'est une raison
supplémentaire de continuer à se battre
pour penser en européen pour avoir de la
coopération
la france a obtenu des choses vis-à-vis
des allemands ce que d'autres pays n'ont
pas obtenu de l'autre côté et frontière
allemande
moi je plaide pour qu'on puisse
harmoniser les choses et que on ne
complique pas plus que ça la vie des
travailleurs transfrontaliers elle est
suffisamment difficile face à cette
crise je pense que les mesures qui ont
été obtenus par la france sont bonnes il
faut s'en réjouir
maintenant c'est sûr il ya une décision
que initialement nous avons regretté
allez on va parler paris et de
l'ile-de-france un placés sous
surveillance renforcée valérie pécresse
de rencontrer cet après midi le préfet
d'ile-de-france le directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé pour discuter de
mesures restrictives c'est jean castex
qui la demandait quelles mesures
restrictives
vous préconisez vous pour paris et l'île
de france côté os on verra j'entendais
hier les propositions de valérie
pécresse je pense qu'elles vont
globalement dans le sens de ce que le
gouvernement a fait dans différentes
régions dans différents départements qui
étaient touchés
elle soumet gouvernement de ne par le
confiner soutient cette ligne j'ai vu
une position constructive mettre le
paquet sur la vaccination pour accélérer
le plus possible les choses mettre le
paquet sur les thèses dans les écoles
c'est ce que le gouvernement prévoit de
faire à partir de cette semaine nous
aurons deux cent mille tests salivaires
dans les écoles de france
toutes les semaines c'est important
évidemment continuer à apporter des
mesures de soutien
peut-être
durcir les choses par rapport à la crise
sanitaire le week-end je ne sais pas on
verra bien ce qui est très important
c'est que les choses se fassent dans la
concertation
on voit que à chaque fois que l'on a pu
embarquer les locaux qui ait eu ce lien
maires préfets dont on a tant parlé et
mesure été mieux acceptée mieux suivis
et c'est ça la clé ce qu'il faut
toujours toujours rappeler c'est que la
solution on la tient entre nos mains
d'une certaine façon par nos
comportements
donc je pense que les mesures qui sont
bien préparées elles sont mieux suivis
et donc plus efficace
forcément des mesures je vois que la
situation francilienne est
redoutablement complexe inquiétante avec
cette question des variants on a une
fenêtre de tir d'une certaine façon pour
éviter leur confinement généralisée de
tout le pays on voit bien que la
stratégie du gouvernement est la bonne
de pousser tous les curseurs au maximum
par le couvre-feu par une politique de
tests qui fonctionne qui fonctionne
d'ailleurs mieux j'entendais juste avant
de venir vous rejoindre
une résidente britannique qui dit moi
j'aurais aimé être française dans cette
période ben oui effectivement il vaut
mieux être français dans cette période
on se teste massivement gratuitement
donc on pousse tous les curseurs pour
éviter le plus possible cette décision
pied jamais exclu de reconfirmer tout le
pays
donc il faut continuer à le faire
localement c'est ce que nous avons fait
en moselle confiné tout le pays puisque
vous êtes député de paris vous avez
entendu la mairie de paris réagir très
rapidement après la conférence de presse
de jean castex même si depuis un peu un
rétropédalage équiperont soit 2 en deçà
de confiner trois semaines la ville de
paris est ce que ça c'est une
proposition qui vous semblent ans que je
crois j'ai été très surpris je t'ai pas
le seul que anne hidalgo a fait une
faute en faisant cette proposition est
trop pédalant le lendemain une faute
politique
on voit bien que une décision comme
celle là elle ne peut pas être annoncé
sans concertation avec les départements
de la petite couronne les départements
de la grande couronne paris n'est pas
une île
donc ça n'avait aucun sens et puis une
faute éthique aussi parce qu'en laissant
croire aux franciliens aux français que
confus mais trois semaines de façon
difficile c'est l'assurance de pouvoir
ré ouvrir ensuite les restaurants les
commerces etc
c'est mentir
et ça c'est grave donc je pense que
c'est une faute
heureusement il n'y a eu ce
rétropédalage que vous avez indiquée
mais on voit bien qu'on a besoin de
concertation qu'on a besoin du sens de
l'intérêt général ne surtout pas mettre
de la mauvaise politique par dessus cela
c'est la ligne de ce gouvernement qui
est une ligne de responsabilité on va
continuer évidemment à la teneur faire
on a vu ce week-end les quais de seine
abonnés à paris les quais du rhône à
lyon lesquels d'ailleurs on à toulouse
on a vu qu'à nice tout on ne partait
pour aller vers la partie du département
qui n'était pas confinée est ce qu'on
risque pas de provoquer des clusters
surtout avec les jours qui vont allonger
leur qui va changer je pense que c'est
tout l'intérêt de la mesure de couvre
feu qui a été mis en place dont on voit
que il y a une efficacité de ce
couvre-feu puisque il vient justement
mettre en cause l'aspect social de ce
virus c'est-à-dire les réunions hors
travail qui peuvent se faire avec des
contaminations dans cette familiale dans
le cercle amical c'est difficile vous
l'avez dit avec les beaux jours qui
reviennent on a tous évidemment envie de
sortir de prendre l'air je pense qu'il
faut tenir c'est exactement ça cette
ligne de crête qu'on essaie de suivre
on voit bien que la politique de
vaccination commence à avoir de l'impact
et c'est d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt d'une
politique de vaccination qui était très
bien ciblé
on voit là aussi si on fait un peu de
comparaisons européennes que la france à
mieux cibler sa politique de vaccination
sur les personnes les plus vulnérables
l'âge moyen des personnes vaccinées est
plus âgé que dans les autres pays
européens
et ça commence à avoir de l'impact sur
les cours dans les ehpad
rappelons que les morts de cette crise
sanitaire c'est un tiers des gens dans
les étals sur les plus de 75 ans et un
quart qui sont maintenant vaccinée
on va continuer à faire comme ça pour
essayer de tenir ce chemin de crête
entre une politique de vaccination qui
commence à porter ses fruits
et puis malheureusement les variants
avec ce variant anglais qui gagnent du
terrain et inexorablement ce mécanique
dans une épidémie de cette nature là là
on va tout faire pour essayer de
continuer à passer dans cette très
minces fenêtre de tir justement puisque
vous parlez des vaccins est ce qu'il
faut changer la stratégie vaccinale pas
sur les classes d'âge mais sur
l'attribution des vaccins actuellement
ils sont attribués en fonction des
habitants dans département
valérie pécresse a dit
rennes plus les attribués en fonction
des habitants en fonction du nombre de
personnes hospitalisées en fonction de
la situation sanitaire est ce que vous
partagez sauvé la vie voyez donc ce
moment je le partage mais c'est ce qu'on
a commencé à faire quand olivier ferrand
se déplace dans les alpes maritimes en
moselle
non mais vous rajoutez les doses des
doses à ceux des départements qui les
ont déjà reçu mais à mes futures
attributions c'est l'airé d'effet ce qui
l'est moins dans l'ouest de la france où
le virus est moins présent il est
partout dans les départements touchés je
les dis mettre le paquet en matière de
vaccination sur les départements les
plus touchés
c'est ce que le gouvernement a fait
quand il a envoyé plus de doses en
moselle dans les alpes maritimes par
exemple c'est ce qu'il faut continuer à
faire à mon sens pour les départements
les plus touchés donc oui c'est
effectivement une idée que nous
partageons comment de se mettre en place
le pass and i ter dont par le président
de la république est là aussi avec de la
concertation avec nos voisins européens
on voit bien que toute solution penser
tout seul dans notre coin est une
solution veine il faut de la
concertation pour que y compris
techniquement ce pas ce qui permettrait
d'emmagasiner les différentes
informations vous avez fait un test pcr
négatif il est nécessaire pour pouvoir
se déployer le genre de retour au cinéma
il pourrait servir à l'intérieur du pays
également oui je pense je pense que ça
pourrait être une solution extrêmement
utile vous savez quand les restaurants
étaient encore ouverts nous avions mis
en place ce système il fallait
manuellement laissé son numéro de
téléphone son nom je pense que tout le
monde s'y prêtait de bonne grâce on a
tous très envie de voir partager des
moments conviviaux restaurant s'il faut
laisser son contact pour le faire je
pense que l'immense majorité des
français seraient prêts à le faire
évidemment bien l'idée c'est de
faciliter la vie des français nous avons
lancé une application tout senti qu vide
qui a avec un peu de difficulté je le
reconnais mais finit par avoir un
certain succès sont aujourd'hui 13
millions de français qui ont téléchargé
cette application on pourrait imaginer
ce type de solution enrichie pour
pouvoir y est emmagasinée toutes les
informations à la fois sur notre thèse
sur nos déplacements pour mieux tracer
l'épidémie mais il faut être très clair
avec les gens qui nous écoutent ce sont
des dispositifs qui sont utiles quand on
est en maîtrise
de l'épidémie dès lors qu'on perd le
contrôle que les courbes augmente de
façon exponentielle alors ce sont les
mesures de durcissement sanitaires qui
sont utiles mais en revanche quand on
est dans une situation intermédiaire à
ce moment là le tester alerté protéger
ce contact racing ben c'est la clé il
faudra évidemment mettre en place ce
type de dispositif manuel macro à
d'ailleurs annoncé une réunion cette
semaine avec le gouvernement sur le
passé une terre vous savez quand elle
aura lieu
non je n'ai pas cette information elle
il a aussi dit qu'il faudrait le faire
en concertation avec nos partenaires
c'était la position de la france au
conseil européen et je pense que c'est
la bonne position est ce que pour le
parlement doit se prononcer sur ce sujet
je pense que comme depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire le parlement doit être
régulièrement consultés réunis il ya eu
des débats article 50-1 avec des votes
dans les moments décisifs de la crise
je pense que si nous sommes dans une
nouvelle phase on parlait d'une phase où
on mettra en place des nouveaux outils
pour lutter contre la crise
alors c'est toujours bon de consulter le
problème d'un humoriste oui le président
ne s'est pas exprimé depuis longtemps
faut-il qu'ils reprennent la parole
saleh le président est très
régulièrement sur le terrain il a à
chaque fois l'occasion de s'exprimer je
pense surtout que le président et la
parole du président compte dans les
moments de virage d'une certaine façon
décisif il ya eu une décision il ya
quelques semaines qui était une décision
politique extrêmement importante c'est à
dire de refuser de remettre le pays sous
cloche je pense que c'était une bonne
décision
je pense d'ailleurs que nos concitoyens
suivent cette décision et sont
reconnaissants au président d'avoir pris
cette décision
la parole du présent elle compte encore
une fois dans des moments décisifs de la
crise je pense que à ce moment là il
pourra exprimer
un dernier mot sur ce sujet il ya une
quarantaine de députés toutes tendances
confondues mais y compris des députés de
la république en marche qui ont signé
hier une tribune dans le journal du
dimanche qui appelle à rouvrir les
restaurant le midi
disons qu'il ya une inégalité entre les
salariés qui bénéficient d'un restaurant
d'entreprise et ceux qui sont obligés de
manger dehors et de manger à leur bureau
est-ce que vous soutenez cette
proposition c'est avec toute l'amitié
que j'ai pour les parlementaires de tous
bords qui ont signé cette tribune je
pense pas que ce soit une bonne
proposition
voyez bien vous m'interrogez et quelques
instants sur les mesures de durcissement
dans un certain nombre
deux départements qui comprendrait qu'au
même moment on assouplissent les
contraintes encore une fois pas de
gaieté de coeur je crois qu'on a tous
très envie de permettre et aux salariés
et à tous les français de pouvoir
retourner au restaurant mais il faut pas
envoyer des messages aussi
contradictoires que celui là ç'aurait et
donc je ne suis pas favorable à cette
proposition
on va parler d'un autre sujet on va
parler de la crise sociale qui touche
notamment les jeunes et valérie pécresse
a fait hier une proposition elle va
créer un air jia c'est un revenu jeune
actif il ya quarante-cinq mille
formations qui vont être proposés en
ile-de-france à partir d'aujourd'hui
six mois de formation 4000 euros pour
les gens qui vont bénéficier de ces
formations avec la garantie d'un métier
à la sortie puisque ce sont des
formations dans des branches qui
recherchent des employés est ce que
c'est une bonne proposition
et là aussi je vais pas faire de
politique politicienne
tant mieux quand les dispositifs vont
dans le même sens en l'occurrence
valérie pécresse annonce là un
dispositif qui est existant est proposée
par le gouvernement
si la région l'amplifient en y mettant
des fonds en connectant bien les tuyaux
autres ce qui peut se faire au niveau
national et puis l'arrivée sur le
terrain tant mieux on va pas commencer à
faire de bisbee sur ces sujets là le
gouvernement a mis en place un bon
nombre de solutions en l'occurrence et
une d'entre elles dans ce plan 7
milliards d'euros quand même dans le
plan de relance
un jeune une solution pour pouvoir
accompagner à hauteur de 500 euros par
mois des jeunes en formation
il faut penser à tous les jeunes ce que
l'on remet sur la route d'une formation
d'un emploi ceux qui sont ni en emploi
ni en formation la situation est
évidemment inquiétante et impactante
pour eux la réponse là c'est la garantie
jeune je crois que c'est extrêmement
important de pouvoir étendre cette
garantie jeunes c'est ce que avec
elisabeth bornes le gouvernement a
décidé de faire passer le 100 milles à
200000 garantie jeunes disponibles là
aussi c'est 500 euros par mois pour tous
ces jeunes l'un d'eux ja sont moins
détendu donc il faut des solutions
adaptées à chaque jeune puisque chaque
jeune est touché par la crise sanitaire
ceux qui sont nés en emploi ni en
formation ceux qui ont perdu leur job
étudiants ceux qui sont étudiants et qui
ont besoin d'être accompagnés et à
chaque fois c'est une pluralité de
solutions qui font mal justement ne
vaut-il pas mieux simplifiée vu
l'ampleur du phénomène crée un une sorte
de revenu minimum ou de rsa jeunes comme
le propose le président de
l'agglomération lyonnaise le diet si
vous les deux niveaux de réponse d'abord
ce plan un jeune une solution c'est
quand même et ces gens parlent
systématiquement l'occasion de le faire
connaître de dire aux jeunes qu'ils nous
écoutent peut-être ce matin d'aller sur
ce site internet puisqu'il ya un million
de solutions qui sont proposées pour les
jeunes et ça donne des résultats
rappelons que nous avons eu 500 milles
apprentis l'année dernière n'a jamais eu
autant de contrats d'apprentissage qui
ont été signés il ya un million de
jeunes depuis août dernier qui ont
prouvé un emploi entre août et la fin
d'année dernière là aussi c'est des
niveaux qui ne sont pas en baisse par
rapport à l'année précédente
donc il ya des solutions mais il faut
simplifier
moi je plaide comme elisabeth bornes
d'ailleurs pour que l'on rende cette
garantie jeunes dans la période
universel ces 500 euros par mois
doublé évidemment d'un accompagnement ça
se fait via les missions locales c'est
efficace c'est un dispositif qui a fait
ses preuves je plaide pour que chaque
jeune qui en est besoin puissent avoir
accès à la garantie jeunes ça serait
évidemment une mesure de simplification
une assurance aussi pendant la crise
sanitaire qui impacte très
douloureusement la jeunesse d'autres
pays que personne ne soit sur le bord de
la route je pense que c'est une bonne
mesure
je continuerai de la poussée avec la
ministre anne animaux puisque vous vous
avez proposé une mesure ainsi un capital
jeunes de 10000 euros
qui sera remboursable uniquement pour
ceux dont la vie active permet le
remboursement si j'ai bien compris
exactement
hong hong et vous de cette idée écoutez
d'abord pour leur dire un mot une
seconde c'est une mesure qui est très
complémentaire de ce qu'on vient de
discuter
là on vient de parler des mesures qui
doivent répondre à l'urgence et aux
besoins du quotidien moi j'ajoute une
proposition qui est une mesure
d'apporter un capital à tous les jeunes
de dix mille euros qui permettrait de se
projeter dans sa vie de financer une
formation mais aussi pourquoi pas de se
déplacer dans une autre ville et
financer un logement étudiant
l'accès à une voiture a permis de
conduire et c'est un capital qu on ne
remboursera est que si on atteint un
certain niveau de revenus sur une durée
très longue 30 ans et à taux zéro je
pense que c'est une bonne mesure
là aussi gelé soumis au président de la
république au projet il vous a dit il à
une réflexion qu'on n'entend plus trop
parler de choc est en cours je pense que
l'exécutif aura l'occasion de prendre
des positions sur cette proposition moi
j'y crois
donc je continuerai à défendre parce que
j'y crois je le pense un mois sur la
convention citoyenne pour wii la
convention citoyenne bien finalement
c'est un peu déceptif vue des citoyens s
kg venue pas et nautile mieux pas valu
prendre peut-être le conseil économique
et social des scientifiques des ong
là ils sont sortis avec un vote négatif
est assez déçu
écoutez je ne partage pas du tout votre
avis pardon beaucoup de jokers et elle
vous que non c'est pas vrai les citoyens
ont fait 149 proposition présente la
république a utilisé trois joker comme
il l'avait dit à 146 propositions qui
seront reprises il ya déjà 70 % des
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat qui sont reprises ou en
cours d'application sur les 146 c'est
sans proposition de façon très concrète
qui vont changer la vie des français
pas moi qui le dit c'est le comité
d'appui justement aux citoyens les
citoyens ils ont eu l'occasion de donner
un certain nombre de bots alors
certaines font pas forcément plaisir
moi je note aussi qu' ils ont dit à plus
de 60% que la convention citoyenne pour
le climat est un exercice qui a permis
de faire avancer les choses dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
à plus de 70% que c'était une mesure ou
plutôt un instrument qui va continuer à
transformer nos démocraties donc moi j'y
crois
la république en marche avait fait cette
proposition de mettre en place cette
convention citoyenne je continue à
penser que cet avis et note 6 2 en
matière de réduction de confronter les
propositions qui ont été faites qui vont
je le dis et le redis dans le bon sens
qui seront appliqués à la réalité
quotidienne des français et de faire en
sorte qu'elles entrent dans l'atmosphère
et maintenant c'est notre responsabilité
à nous les parlementaires de voter la
loi une loi qui convienne à tous les
français n'oublions pas que derrière
chaque mesure
il ya des gens qui vivent ces
changements là je veux pas qu un jour on
est le débat pour le climat et puis le
lendemain on dise ah oui mais
agriculteurs sont à grimma chez les
restaurateurs qui ont des terrasses on
les pousse à enlever leurs dispositifs
de se fasse sans transition bien ans
on veut laisser personne sur le bord du
chemin c'est peut-être pour ça que ça
donne l'impression parfois que les
choses vont pas suffisamment vite mais
moi je n'ai pas oublié la première
moitié du quinquennat
nous avions mis une taxe carbone sur la
table et puis les gilet jaune parce que
les gens se sentent et au fond agressés
dans leur mode de vie bien je crois une
écologie qui n'oppose pas les uns aux
autres qui n'oppose pas comme on l'a
beaucoup dit la fin du monde
à la fin du mois là c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de faire je pense que ce
quinquennat sera le quinquennat le plus
vert de l'histoire depuis le début du
quinquennat nous avons fait beaucoup sur
les énergies sur la fin des plastiques
sur la consommation durable
nous allons continuer à changer le
quotidien des français avec c'est toi
qui traduira un grand nombre de
propositions des citoyens sur la fin des
vols intérieurs sur la fin des passoires
thermiques sur l'artificialisation des
sols
ce sont des grandes avancées il faut
qu'on les pousse tous ensemble mais
surtout qu'on arrive à embarquer nos
concitoyens moi je pense que c'est ça la
clé pour une écologie qui transforme
réellement le quotidien et cette loi qui
sera examiné en personne la semaine
prochaine par les députés on termine en
parlant de politique d'élection et vous
avez vu cette une de libé en ce week-end
cette enquête sur ces électeurs de
gauche qui disent qu'ils ne voteront
plus emmanuel macron pour faire barrage
au rassemblement national vous venez de
la gauche gagnait 16 guérini est ce que
c'est un échec pour vous savez surtout
je crois que faut arrêter de vivre avec
la politique fiction mais à un an et
demi d'une élection président
ciel et déjà on voit un certain nombre
de débats parfois avec un petit côté on
se demande ce n'est pas une profession
de réalisatrice voiliers de se faire
peur de dire les gens viendront
viendront pas voté et c'est à la semoy
est témoin lancé c'est une enquête mais
l'agencé gauche et disent qu'ils ne
voteront plus sont exactement les débats
pardon mais qui éloigne les gens de la
vie politique parce que elles font des
projections parfois un peu malsaine
je le dis je vois un certain nombre de
dirigeants de gauche qui les a renvoyés
on vous l'avait bien dit et c'est je
pense pas que c'est comme ça que les
choses doivent se faire
moi je crois qu'on doit transformer la
vie des gens et alors on gagne le droit
peut-être de se représenter une élection
de continuer à exercer des
responsabilités
moi quand je me déplace sur le terrain
j'ai pas du tout ce type de débat savoir
si déjà on est dans le deuxième tour je
pense que les gens sont même pas encore
dans l'élection régionale ou
départementale qui vient que déjà on
veut les mettre dans l'élection
présidentielle mais j avoue qu'il a mais
entre eux qu'ils ont entre autres un
clivage and is less guérini entre d'un
côté emmanuel macron et de l'autre
marine le pen mais je sais en revanche
que vous entendiez européenne notamment
nous sommes à chaque fois ce qui nous
battons matin midi et soir contre le
rassemblement national mais pas que dans
l'implantation pas que dans la politique
fiction par les résultats
on voit bien que à chaque fois qu'on
obtient des résultats à chaque fois
qu'on transforme la vie des gens sur le
terrain concrètement et toutes les
discussions que nous venons d'avoir en
sont la démonstration à chaque fois
qu'on protège les français comme on l'a
fait pendant cette crise
eh bien on fait reculer ce qui constitue
l'éternel boutique du front national
c'est à dire la peur c'est à dire les
difficultés et ne vivent que là dessus
donc moi je ne crois qu'à une seule
solution pas penser en termes de une de
libé penser en termes de solutions
penser en termes de transformation
concrètes pour nos concitoyens et alors
peut-être nous pourrons un jour avoir
une autre adversaire que marine le pen
en face de nous deuxième tour avec son
présent set et alors nous aurons réussi
ce que nous devons proposer aux france
puisqu'on parle de rassemblement
national le prochain combat dans les
urnes que ce sera les régionales jordan
bardella annonce ce matin sa candidature
en ile de france ce sera lui le candidat
du rassemblement national valérie
pécresse sera sûrement candidate à sa
succession est ce que laurent saint
martin est en mesure de gagner cette
région où je pense je le pensais au fur
et à mesure que cette élection va se
lancer pour l'instant
on le disait n'est pas encore
complètement dans la tête de nos
concitoyens sont des enjeux qui sont
extrêmement importants on va voir toute
la qualité de ce candidat qui
rassemblera la majorité présidentielle
qui rassemblera comme dans toutes les
régions
les différentes formations politiques de
la majorité présidentielle pour proposer
un projet aux franciliens pour mettre en
cohérence aussi ce que nous faisons au
plan national
je pense qu'il ya un enjeu qui est
absolument essentiel qui est le plan de
relance l'accélération de ce plan de
relance
laurent saint martin c'est le rapporteur
du budget à l'assemblée nationale il
sera à ça aussi un élu local
évidemment il sera porté ce projet de la
majorité du clj le gobal c'est d'avoir
des élus ou c'est de gagner les régions
vous savez à chaque fois qu on se
présente à une élection c'est évidemment
pour convaincre ici ghazi un patron
marché donc nous nous voyons bien et
nous abordons cette élection avec aussi
beaucoup d'humilité
nous nous sommes entrant dans cette
élection la majorité présidentielle sera
rassemblée pour proposer des projets
autour de la relance au tour des jeunes
autour de l'europe aussi puisqu'il faut
un lien entre les régies jusqu'à un
dernier mot rapide et à nice vous dites
avec toutes les émotions de la majorité
présidentielle ça veut dire y compris le
modem
j'en suis convaincu nous travaillons
depuis des mois pour justement porter
cette offre pour les élections
intermédiaires pour les élections
régionales
ensemble ce que nous faisons et
commencer les combats de valérie
pécresse avec des gens qui ont gouverné
bien dans la sécurité elle quand on
éclaire sur le projet qu'on propose
je viens d'en dire quelques mots sur la
lutte contre les fractures territoriales
sur la mise en oeuvre de ce plan de
relance sur les solutions à apporter aux
jeunes et bien cela donne du sens à
rassembler toutes celles et ceux qui
autour du président de la république se
battent ensemble matin midi et soir
justement pour mettre ses solutions et
joue assez claire de commettre valérie
pécresse avec des gens qui ont eu la
joie dans un combat contre je suis dans
un projet positif je suis pour porter
des idées c'est comme ça que nous avons
convaincu en 2017
je pense que cette élection régionale
c'est aussi l'occasion de renouer
davantage avec ce discours positif de
proposition et laurent saint martin
comme nos autres candidats dans les
autres régions ils portent ont
exactement la campagne de cette façon là
c'est à dire de façon positive et c'est
là où on gagne le droit ensuite de
convaincre nos concitoyens
si beaucoup entre nous en parlent et
disent ils moins ce qu'espère merci
stanislav arrêté avec no mercy parce
qu'elle est la mère
[Musique]